how are you Kurt I am great how are you
my friend tell me what about what you
thought you you've put on glove you wore
gloves as a quarterback you know what
that means what it might not mean what a
hand injury might be what does it mean
Kurt tell me what it means
well it's New England so we have no idea
of what it means at the end of the day
until till Sunday happens but you know
it's an interesting thing if you haven't
worn gloves before it takes a little bit
of time to get used to it because the
biggest thing for a quarterback is you
always want to touch the football you
want to have a feel of the football
because it it changes everything
so when you throw on a glove for the
first time you don't have that same
connection with the football the same
feel of it so it can throw you off so I
don't know if Tom's worn gloves and
practice in the past and and done all of
that but if he's doing it for the first
time he could definitely be an
adjustment period with that being said I
believe there's also some benefits that
you can get from it especially if your
hand is injured or weak you know we went
to our last Super Bowl running to the
Super Bowl run in Arizona I had broken
my index finger that year and I
remembered just say I mean I was already
wearing gloves but I remembered later in
the year I took off my glove and just
said you know I wonder if I could play
without the glove with this with this
finger and I tried to throw it and I had
very little grip strength to it I really
struggled because it was my index finger
where I really released the football and
I don't know if I could have played had
I not warn the gloves that year so it
gave me enough of a benefit enough of
attack on the football me to control it
the way I wanted to
so that could be a huge benefit
depending on the extent or what exactly
this injury is for Tom Brady but gosh
we're all gonna look closely and we're
all gonna wait and see if he is wearing
a glove or what exactly the injury was
but yeah I just have a funny feeling
that he's practicing today already that
it's not it's not overly severe so what
is his history of glove Brocklin what is
it does he he doesn't wear it right he
never he never wears gloves playing I
mean I maybe remember game or two but
right
okay so he's putting a glove on the left
hand maybe could have let's see that
doesn't mean he hasn't used it in
practice okay so it gets cold out there
in the practicing outside okay so even
if he just practices with it here and
there he could develop and that's like
Ben Roethlisberger that's what he does
is you'll see him in cold weather games
pull out the glove but he's used them at
different times in the past just doesn't
use it on a normal basis well let's put
a pin in the mention of Ben
Roethlisberger because I definitely want
to hit that subject matter with you
being a quarterback who has been
coordinated by Todd Haley successfully I
might add here on the Rich Eisen show
we'll talk about that with Kurt Warner
but what about this Jacksonville defense
matchup with New England it sure seems
like this is their they have what might
be the recipe to beat Tom Brady at home
in the playoffs your thoughts Kurt
Warner well yeah I mean I think on paper
and what you've seen at times this year
without question we talked about it all
the time on our shall we any great
quarterback but especially Tom Brady
quick pressure is what messes with him
where he's got to throw it before he
wants to not the most mobile guy where
he's got to move his feet those are key
you know Jacksonville can obviously get
after the passer but the key is always
the push up the middle you can always
step away from edge pressure you can't
step away from pressure up the middle so
that's going to be a key and we know
they can do it but I look back to last
week against Pittsburgh and they
struggled to do it against Pittsburgh
you know and Pittsburgh's got a good
offensive line some of the Patriots but
that's gonna be key it's quick pressure
the other thing I look at in this
matchup is you know we're gonna talk
about booyeah and Ramsey and those guys
you know all weekend long but what we
know about the Patriots is that nobody
attacks inside the numbers on the hashes
better than the Patriots with their
running backs with Gronk with their two
tight end sets in the past is that we're
going to talk about those guys on the
edge because they're really really good
I just have a funny feeling that you're
gonna see a lot of the throws for the
Patriots happen inside the numbers
running away from those guys on the
edges because they know that's the
strength of their team and it's going to
come down to those safeties and
Macker covering in space in between the
numbers so that to me is the intriguing
matchup about all of this is that I
don't know if the Patriots have the guys
to say hey we can go and attack Ramsey
on the outside one on one and we're
gonna win that consistently no but I
think they say we got the guys on the
inside with our facts and our tight ends
to attack anybody and to put a lot of
pressure on those inside linebackers and
safeties and that's gonna be the matchup
to watch in my opinion Kurt Warner who
will be right to my left on NFL gameday
morning championship Sunday edition with
by the way
LeSean McCoy Michael Bennett and Joe
Hayden a show that started 10 minutes
ago
joining me here now on the Rich Eisen
show how do you see the NFC Championship
game playing out Kirk you know I'm still
wrestling with this one yeah but people
ask me who I'm picking I'm not sure who
I'm picking yet I think like everybody I
see this as being a defensive match up
you know with the weather with where
these two teams are defensively the
defensive front I think it is going to
be a defensive matchup I don't think
it's gonna be really high scoring and
it's gonna put the the owner squarely on
the shoulders of those quarterbacks you
know who makes the most big plays or you
know maybe the vice versa who doesn't
make the big mistake I mean if one thing
Nick Foles did great last week is he
made the plays he was supposed to make
and didn't make any big mistakes case on
the other hand made that one big mistake
that almost cost them the game but was
able to obviously make a couple big
plays to offset that but I think that's
going to be to tell all with the
pressure up front which of these
quarterbacks manages that the best and
maybe makes one or two big plays that
separates his team because I think both
of these teams are really good up front
especially defensively the front seven
you know I think that the Vikings back
in is a little bit better and they're
gonna be a little more aggressive so not
give you as much room for air as it may
be Philly will but they're both really
really good how incredible was that
final play in Minnesota Kurt I was right
I mean it's unbelievable and you know
we're actually gonna show it on the show
and I don't know you
her this but it was funny that you
looked at difference making plays for
both of these teams the last play that
Philly ran in the first half to set up
that field goal where they hit out Sean
Jeffrey I think it was was the exact
same play that the Vikings ran to win
their game when they threw it to Diggs
and you know it's like three three
levels of out routes because you know
you have to get out of bounds and
Atlanta took away the deep one so Philly
hit the middle one case was looking for
the middle one and the Saints took it
away leaving one on one on the back end
and he hit the the deep shot which is
probably not what he wanted to do as a
quarterback but obviously worked out in
their favor but pretty incredible
because it's a play that a lot of people
run and both teams had success with it
that set up a key score that ultimately
advanced them to that's the sort of
insight you get from Kurt Warner on NFL
gameday morning here on the riches and
showing again with my wife and I his
podcast this week all right Kurt let's
get into it I know you know Todd Haley
for many many years and you know what
it's like to be a quarterback in this
league I want you to interpret this was
Big Ben's comments on his radio show
this week when asked about that was
fourth and inches calls why were there
were no sneaks I would love the
quarterback sneak like I said we don't
we can call it in the huddle but there's
no way for me to audible to it without
telling guys hey our backs weak like
yeah hope the defensive line didn't hear
does that make sense that that that Ben
didn't have an ability to audible to a
quarterback seen Kurt yeah it makes
complete sense I never had that ability
either we did the same thing that if we
wanted to run it we called it you know
every once in a while against certain
teams that would maybe play a little
wider with their tackles or whatever we
would put in a call those weeks but it
wasn't something that I had on on in
every situation where I could just go to
a quarterback sneak because he just it's
not something that you check to brilli
often if you're in that scenario you
know you could easily say call
quarterback sneak and if you don't like
to look check to this but I never check
to a quarterback sneak so that doesn't
surprise me as much in that situation
you know I don't know how the details
went down
I would be surprised if he didn't have a
couple options though to either run or
pass based on you know what scenario
they got from Jacksonville in those
situations so because I'll be honest
with you I was stunned to hear that a
quarterback has no ability to just take
the potentially easiest way out Kurt in
that situation is that specific to a
Halley offense or is that specific to
any offense I don't think I ever had
that but I also wasn't necessarily great
at running quarterback sneak so six foot
nine and 400 pounds I was a Cam Newton
there or what hurry so you know maybe
that was part of it but I mean I know I
don't ever remember having the ability
in any office I was in to check to a
quarterback sneak because again if
you're in fourth and inches I mean
what's gonna make me check to it I mean
just call it if you want it if you think
there's a better play than then call the
better play you know that's how we
always dealt with it as I felt like if
they felt we could get it with a
quarterback it just called it and we
just live with it it wasn't a check to
side play so that was just not something
in the offensive that I had I don't know
if that's a common thing in Ascension I
would think it would be in offenses
where the quarterbacks really good at it
or athletic like you know like a Cam
Newton but but now I never had that
ability did does Big Ben over share Kurt
do you know what I mean I just lost Kurt
on a very crucial member moment of our
interview did he do we just lose him
right there yeah we can we just you just
you just uh oh there you go does this
Big Ben over share with the media um
well I mean I would say more than over
share I think it's selective sharing and
I think I think we all do it I think
coaches do it I think players do it that
you have certain things that you might
want to get out there and so you see or
that you might not hear the whole story
in every situation because you don't
want it to get out there you don't want
people to know the whole story and so
yeah I think sometimes when guys are and
again not just Ben it's a lot of guys
you have to read but
clean the lines okay what are they
trying to say that you know what what's
what's really the point of that comment
because that comment in and of itself
really didn't need to be said or in most
situations you might not share it so
yeah I think you have to get a little
deeper dive a little deeper or look
between the lines a lot of times when
when different guys specifically are
talking and I think yeah Ben can be that
way sometimes so then why do you think
it didn't work out between Warner and
Haley in Pitt's honor what you can share
yeah I mean again I think it was solely
you know personal based in regards to
just you know sometimes we have guys
that we don't fit with coaches that
don't seem to to mesh with our
personality I mean you can't look at
what Todd's done from a football
standpoint whether it be in the past and
what he did with us in Arizona or what
he's done there I mean he's made Ben a
better quarterback a more complete
quarterback in the stats bear that out
I mean lay beyond you know you could
argue the best running back in the
league or the most versatile running
back in the league and then a B has been
the best receiver with the best stats
for a year so he's done his job as an
offense coordinator in scoring points
and putting them in positions over and
over again I think you solely have to
look at it as personally those two
didn't mesh and we talked about it on
our show last week we were talking about
it early on in the stages where they
were coming together and and just being
with Todd I understand why people say
that and I understand where that could
go sideways you know Todd and I even got
into it at times and I didn't get into
it with a lot of guys but I also knew at
the end of the day hey Todd was gonna
make me better and be everything Todd
did was from a competitive standpoint
was from a standpoint of I want us to be
the best I want to be the best I want
you to be the best and that's what I'm
gonna push you towards I don't care what
you've accomplished I don't care how
long you've been in the league I don't
care what you did last week I'm gonna
coach you on this situation in hopes of
making you you better and making us
better and when you understand that and
when I understood that it was like
I don't want to play for anybody but a
guy like that now you can do it
different way sure but I want to play
for a guy that just wants to be the best
and wants to push everybody I saw him
getting Larry Fitzgerald face numerous
times about blocking and run after catch
and all of that stuff that made Larry
better and it would have been easy to
just go man he's really good let's just
leave him where he's at and everybody
else has to play better but that's not
how you Todd is Todd is a guy that will
push you and get in your face and is not
afraid to challenge even the best
players in the league if he thinks he
can make them better and I appreciated
that and I understand why a lot of
people look at that and kind of keep
them at arm's length like oh man I don't
know if I want those kind of outbursts
or a guy with you know that kind of
demeanor on my sideline I tell you what
if you're a competitor and you want to
win whether you're an organization a
head coach or a player you want a guy
like that in your corner you want a guy
like that pushing you every day and
taking you to the next level all right
Kurt last one for you do you think if I
spend the next 48 hours 48 hours from
now we're gonna be 90 minutes from
kickoff to the AFC Championship game so
if I spend the next 48 hours talking
myself into choosing Jacksonville on
game day morning do you think I will be
lone wolf thing yea or nay what do you
think I'm gonna say yeah I'm gonna say
probably just because it's so hard to
pick against the patch at home in this
situation mm-hmm but I'm telling you
that you won't be the only one that has
a little bit of a leaning to pick
Jacksonville right I think they have I
think they have the right pieces I think
there are very competent bunch there
either's not going to be overwhelmed by
the situation I'm just not sure
anybody's going to be willing to step
out on that limb and take them pick in
this situation okay I might be are you
going to really thinking about it Kurt
about it I know there's lots of people
that are thinking about it I'm just not
sure I can pull that trigger we'll see
at the meeting on tomorrow and then all
day Sunday you're the best Kurt thanks
for calling that Kurt won the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience